[Música]
este es el espacio ambiental de france
24 hoy hablaremos de algunas iniciativas
que ayudan a combatir la crisis
climática ya preservar la biodiversidad
y empezamos en hollywood porque en el
mundo del cine y la televisión están
intentando incluir más historias
relacionadas con el medio ambiente la
ong good energy y 50 agencias más
lanzaron una guía sobre cómo contar el
cambio climático alejándose de los
relatos apocalípticos va desde porque
incluir en la pantalla hábitos para
proteger al medio ambiente hasta como no
aumentar la llamada ansiedad climática
que es la preocupación por la realidad
que vive el planeta e incluso hay una
lista de expertos a consultar en france
24 hablamos con samuel wing fundador de
jong entertainment activista una agencia
que contribuyó a la elaboración de la
guía él nos contó cuál es la importancia
del good energy playbook
y para mí es un recurso maravilloso para
expertos en comunicación para guionistas
que se puede encontrar en www
granel historia puntocom playbook y que
puedes leerlo desde el móvil de la
tablet desde el ordenador mientras
escribes revisas haces investigación
para tus proyectos narrativos y que es
una caja de pandora de sorpresas de
inspiración y muchas ideas para
replantear cuál es el enfoque pero
cuando promovemos la acción climática
sobre todo cuando lo hacemos o no lo
hacemos en la televisión y series que
consumimos la misma razón por la que es
importante hablar de la crisis climática
en series y películas es por la que es
importante hablar de justicia racial
justicia económica y porque el impacto
social que tiene el cine y la televisión
personalmente creo que a veces es más
poderoso que las ciencias políticas el
poder de las historias para movilizar
las acciones climáticas
esencia detrás del good energy playbook
y para construirlo consultar a más de
100 escritores y productores de
hollywood y de todo eeuu también le
preguntaron a científicos y activistas
mientras que actores como rosario 2 son
un mar cruzado apoya en la iniciativa el
clima es la historia más grande de
nuestro tiempo y no sólo tienen que ser
historias de pérdida y desesperación
también pueden ser historias de valentía
humanidad grandes ideas y nuevas
posibilidades de cada comunidad en medio
de la creación de la guía good energy y
media impact de la universidad del sur
de california analizaron las historias
de cine y televisión lanzados en eeuu
entre 2016 y 2020
de los casi 37 mil 500 guiones
estudiados sólo el 2,8 por ciento
incluían palabras claves del cambio
climático entonces para mí el incremento
de guiones que tratan más sobre la
crisis climática tiene que ir acompañado
con un aumento de la representación de
historias que le ven light
interseccional y that del movimiento
climático porque además afecta
primordialmente a comunidades negras la
tienes indígenas de todo el mundo y
migrantes que padecen en primera línea
los efectos del cambio climático así que
en una industria donde hay mucho que
hacer para hacer colonizar las
narrativas que vemos la pantalla
incluirlas la realidad climática va a ir
de la mano con este esfuerzo tan
importante
y es así como el good energy playbook
virtual ya ha llegado a más de 10.000
escritores en todo el mundo y las
acciones climáticas no paran allí del 22
al 26 de junio se realizará el hollywood
climate summit un evento virtual y
gratuito que desde 2020 reúne a gente de
hollywood con activistas climáticos para
apoyarse y crear historias
la hollywood climate summit va a ser un
evento completamente gratuito híbrido
virtual cinco días de actividades
centradas en el desarrollo de historias
que traten la realidad climática con
workshops online para escritores y
guionistas sobre cómo incluir estos
temas y realidades intuiciones de manera
interactiva práctica y súper divertida
por canciones que también queremos que
la hollywood haim en también sea un
espacio de creación inspiración y si
quieres unirte al movimiento y quieres
participar puedes ir a la página web
hollywood gamer gmail.com
en colombia hay otra iniciativa
ambiental donde el plástico reciclado es
el protagonista en arauca un
departamento que limita con venezuela
viviana mantilla creó un programa que
recoge las bolsas tiradas en los ríos
para convertirlas en carteras y
accesorios maraca nació en 2019 luego de
que a viviana le regalaron un bolso
tejido con bolsas plásticas la creadora
era doll y rivera una campesina de 80
años desde entonces bibiana ha replicado
la técnica entonces cómo se hace lo que
hacemos es recuperar las bolsas
y también los envoltorios que les
comentó el azúcar de la sal y esto lo
hacemos por lo menos en campañas en el
río hemos hecho campañas en el río
arauca recuperando la bolsa aquí como
está en la abuela fotico esto y también
también en campañas acá en saravena y lo
que hacemos es entregar árboles y
semillas a cambio de las de estas bolsas
para cada tenido tanto alcance que fue
uno de los finalistas de los premios
latinoamérica verde de 2021 y su técnica
de crochet con hilos de plástico y
replicada por decenas de mujeres en
arauca y de colombia pasamos a europa
donde se registró un récord
2021 fue el año en el que más
estructuras se retiraron de los ríos
para facilitar el tránsito de los peces
con 239 barreras removidas en 17 países
europeos españa fue el líder al quitar
108 obstáculos incluida la presa más
alta removida de 13 metros de alto en
finlandia incluso desmantelaron una
represa que estaba en funcionamiento la
organización danny mobile europe calcula
que hay por lo menos 150 mil barreras
obsoletas que se deben remover para
ayudar a lograr un objetivo climático 25
mil kilómetros de ríos con flujo libre
para 2023 así se combate la reducción de
los peces migratorios de agua dulce que
en el viejo continente han caído un 93
por ciento
y llegamos así al final de nuestro
programa consulten este y otra
información ambiental en france24 punto
com nos vemos
[Música]